aside from Amazon eBay is likely the
most well-known online retailer in the
entire world they've been around for
nearly 30 years and they rank as the
23rd most visited website in the US
pulling in more than 600 million visits
every single month for perspective
that's nearly double the visits that
even Netflix gets but Legacy and
popularity are pretty much the only
things that are still going for eBay
behind the scenes eBay has been facing a
decline for basically this entire
Century in fact the only time that eBay
stock has seen a significant surge over
the past 25 years was when they decided
to spin off PayPal into its own business
before that eBay stock was mostly flat
and after that eBay stock is still
mostly flat except for the pandemic
boost which has completely subsided for
contrast here's how Amazon stock graph
looks over the same time period And when
we take a look at the company's
fundamentals it's not surprising why
eBay's Revenue today is about the same
as what it was back in
2010 and things only look worse in terms
of net income as recent as last year
eBay had a negative 12-month period
where they lost $1.2 billion since then
they have recovered back into the green
but again the numbers really aren't that
much better than 2010 the one thing that
eBay still has going for them is their
net margins of 27% which are leagues
ahead of Amazon who sits at just
3.62% however it doesn't seem like
investors really care much about this as
they're far more optimistic about
Amazon's future that's why Amazon still
has a PE ratio of 80 while eBay only has
a PE ratio of 8 even IBM has a PE ratio
of 21 meaning that investors are almost
three times more optimistic about IBM
than eBay and when you consider that
many analysts consider eBay to be all
but dead their lackluster valuation
isn't all that surprising but it does
leave the question of what in the world
happened to
eBay when you scour the web for concerns
regarding eBay one of the biggest
concerns seems to be that sales are
falling off a cliff and this sentiment
has especially picked up over the past 6
months as there's a bunch of prevalent
theories floating around for example
student loan payments restarted recently
meaning that a lot of people now have
less disposable income inflation and
high interest rates have also been
eating into people savings some sellers
even speculate that the sales drought
may have been caused by an eBay
algorithm change in April on the surface
it seems that a lot of these
explanations make sense but the evidence
doesn't exactly back up these theories
for example Amazon and Walmart are still
posting record Revenue numbers and eBay
themselves are posting relatively flat
Revenue not to mention concerns about
falling sales seems to be a consistent
theme throughout history in BAS
basically any given year you can go on
Reddit and find a bunch of sellers
claiming that sales are worse than ever
with that being said though this doesn't
necessarily mean that they're wrong the
reality is that selling on eBay is
indeed harder than ever but not because
of macroeconomic reasons but competition
back in 2009 eBay only had a total of
2.1 million annual active sellers today
eBay has a total of 18.3 million annual
active sellers or nine times more it's
it's a similar case with Amazon 2o but
there's one crucial difference Amazon's
revenue has grown 22x since 2009 eBay's
revenue on the other hand has only
increased by
15% and a lot of that can actually be
explained by consistently increasing
fees if we take a look at the gross
merchandise volume going through eBay we
can see that the figure is lower than it
was way back in 2013 and that's not even
accounting for inflation since 2009
prices have gone up up by 43% meaning
that flat Revenue could actually be
indicative of up to 30% lower unit sales
and given that eBay's overall
transactional Revenue itself is down
eBay's overall unit sales could actually
be down by as much as 40% when you
combine 40% lower unit sales with nine
times the number of sellers it's no
wonder why sellers are always
complaining about sales going down the
reality is that it could be as much as
10 to 15 times harder to get a sale
today than it was back in 2009 and all
of that is just on the seller side of
things the buyer side of things don't
look any better as eBay has been
shedding users like the plague in fact
they didn't even enjoy a bounce during
the pandemic their Peak user count was
way back in 2018 when they had 175
million annual users today that number
stands at 129 million users or nearly 50
million less and this is of course anoto
but if you Google I will never buy from
eBay again you get dozens upon dozens of
links that that's not how it is with
Amazon or Walmart or even Craigslist
sure they have a few threads like that
here and there but with eBay it's
basically ubiquitous and when you
combine this anecdotal evidence with the
fact that eBay is down nearly 50 million
buyers it's clear that these threads
aren't just from disgruntled customers
rather it seems to be a serious problem
with eBay as a whole which brings us
into the question of why are customers
so mad at eBay in the first
place
reading through the dozens of negative
threads about eBay it seems that by far
the biggest complaint from buyers is the
prevalence of scams on eBay you know not
receiving the product counterfeit
products damaged products empty boxes
fake tracking numbers and so on most of
these scams are covered by EB money back
guarantee policy but going through that
process is usually not all that fun even
if you do end end up getting your money
back so naturally buyers are preferring
to shop at other retailers where scams
are much less prevalent like Amazon
which brings me into the primary
difference between Amazon and eBay FBA
if you're not familiar with FBA it
stands for fulfilled by Amazon and it's
basically the bread and butter of the
entire website you see Amazon isn't just
a Marketplace like eBay or Craigslist
it's much more of a traditional retailer
as they take on the entire
responsibility of customer service
everything from Distributing inventory
routing orders labeling and two-day
shipping to handling returns covering
damages and customer service that's what
Amazon FBA offers the only thing that
sellers have to do on Amazon is create a
listing and send inventory to Amazon and
Amazon will take care of the rest now
technically sellers can still elect to
do all of this themselves but 94% of
sellers just go through Amazon FBA and
6% of sellers that don't use Amazon FBA
are usually big Brands who can handle it
themselves ironically even a lot of big
Brands like Samsung prefer to just go
through Amazon FBA themselves what all
of this means is that you virtually
never interact with the seller on Amazon
you basically only interact with Amazon
Amazon even goes as far as taking
responsibility for shipping and Order
related mishaps for example let's say a
customer leaves a poor review because of
a lost or damaged package not only will
Amazon remove this negative review but
they will emburse both the buyer and
seller because it was Amazon's fault not
the buyer or Sellers and that's why the
service is so consistent and reliable
especially in comparison to eBay where
it truly is just a Marketplace of buyers
and sellers the quality of the service
you receive is largely dependent on how
much the given seller cares and it's
largely up to you to look out for
yourself eBay did launch their own
fulfillment service back in mid 2019 but
it never quite caught on like Amazon FBA
because eBay sellers often have vastly
different goals a a bunch of eBay
listings are just people selling one-off
items that they no longer need for which
a fulfillment service doesn't really
make sense a fulfillment service makes
much more sense if you're trying to
build a full-on business around a given
product that you plan on selling in
large quantities so with that being said
I don't think eBay's consistency and
reliability will be improving anytime
soon which brings us into the root
question which is why even use
eBay
taking a step back it seems that the
biggest problem with eBay is that they
offer no real value for what they charge
they're over here charging sellers 15%
on a bunch of categories just like
Amazon does but they don't offer any of
the perks that Amazon does they don't
have the same reliability the reputation
or the convenience they're more like a
flea market that truly just connects
buyers and sellers which in itself isn't
a bad thing there's definitely a place
for this sort of Market online but if
this truly is just a flea market that
doesn't come with any of the protections
that Amazon has on the buyer or seller
side why even bother with eBay eBay is
essentially charging Amazon or Walmart
level fees while offering Craigslist or
Facebook Marketplace level of service if
this was a new business eBay wouldn't
even stand a chance but since they're
already established and have brand
recognition a lot of people still shop
on from time to time until they get
burned after which they never return the
people who want more reliability and
convenience just switch over to buying
and selling on Amazon while the people
who don't care to have a dead weight
middle party like eBay just switch to
Craigslist the only unique reason to
come to eBay at this point is their
auctions which in themselves have a
bunch of shortfalls like people placing
bids that they have no intention of
following through with and I think all
of these relative shortfalls can be
explained by the fun fundamentally
different business models of Amazon eBay
and the Craigslist Jeff Bezos has always
believed that other people's margin is
his opportunity this is how he built up
Amazon and it's still how it's run today
that's why Amazon is able to offer so
much value for the prices they charge
they simply don't make any money
remember how we talked about Amazon's
margins being
3.62% well that's with AWS propping up
their retail numbers without AWS and
Amazon's operating margin is closer to
1.8% and it's often negative actually
the reality is that Amazon doesn't care
all that much about making money from
their retail operation their retail
business is more about Market control
brand awareness and influence their real
money maker is AWS meanwhile Craigslist
doesn't really care at all to maximize
profits they're almost run like a
nonprofit with very modest profits and
they have no plans of changing that so
eBay is basic basically competing
against two zero margin businesses and
they're getting squeezed from both sides
and the more time that passes the more
apparent eBay 27% margin becomes in
comparison to the competition the worst
part is that there is no obvious
solution they don't have an AWS that
they can rely on for profits well
actually technically they did use to
have all of PayPal but that's no longer
the case and I think it's safe to assume
that eBay also does not want to become a
quasi nonprofit like Craigslist so
they're kind of stuck between a rock and
a hard place the only way they can
really move forward is by sacrificing
profits and becoming more competitive
but that's not something they really
want to do so instead they've basically
just decided to enjoy the traffic and
profits while they still last which
should still be for quite some time when
things do eventually become
unsustainable well they'll deal with
that then and that right there is the
sad state of eBay they've been reduced
from being one of the most dominant
online retailers to resorting to milking
Sellers as much as possible while they
still can unlike eBay Craigslist has a
much happier ending as they truly know
who they are and what they stand for
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
one